Everyone wants to be the hero, but it’s
not always worse to be the second banana.
Throughout Hollywood history, some of the
most memorable characters have been of the
supporting variety, giving their leading man
or woman a helping hand throughout their adventure.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Greatest Movie
Sidekicks.
Dr. King Schultz – Django Unchained
On a mission to save his wife from the vicious
Calvin Candie, Django is accompanied by his
partner and mentor Dr. King Schultz; the man
who not only showed the film’s hero the
ropes of the bounty hunting business, but
became his greatest friend, treating him as
an equal during their time together.
Through their interactions, it was easy to
see that Schultz loved and admired Django
for a number of reasons.
Their bond is what makes Schultz’s death
all the more upsetting, but also made Django’s
final revenge even sweeter.
The term “sidekick” may sell Schultz’s
role short, but with Django the obvious hero,
actor Christoph Waltz simply did that good
a job in playing second fiddle.
Ron and Hermione – Harry Potter films
At a young age, Harry Potter is proclaimed
as the saviour of the wizard world and the
only person capable of stopping the Dark Lord
Voldemort.
That’s enough to make any teenager crack,
but luckily Harry had his two best friends
Ron and Hermione to help him along the way.
Throughout the series, the two brought valuable
traits to the table: smarts, loyalty, and
courage.
All of which were useful in aiding Harry complete
his quests.
From playing a deadly game of wizard’s chess
to tracking down the Deathly Hallows, Ron
and Hermione displayed bravery well beyond
their years to make the trio a well-rounded
unit.
Walter – The Big Lebowski
His methods may be a tad extreme for some,
but the rule-abiding Walter is a great friend
nonetheless.
As the Dude tries to make sense of his mistaken
identity caper, Walter was there every step
of the way, doing whatever was necessary in
the name of helping his friend.
It takes a special relationship to take a
crowbar to a new car, or put your religious
beliefs aside in the name of accomplishing
the mission, and for all their disagreements,
it’s clear the Dude and Walter are inseparable
pals.
As the film’s hero would see it, they act
as yin and yang, with Walter representing
the more brash emotion to Dude’s laid-back
worldview.
Not to mention asking the question we often
ask ourselves.
Short Round – Indiana Jones and the Temple
of Doom
Indiana Jones had many allies, but few could
top the youngster Short Round.
Despite his age, the kid proved that he had
a knack for archeology, with his intuition
and courage his most valuable assets.
He’s arguably the true hero of the series’
second film, essentially saving Indy from
mind control and leading the charge in rescuing
the movie’s kidnapped children.
Short Round’s emotional connection with
Dr. Jones made him a fan-favorite, and his
strong moral compass was always there to guide
Indy down the right path.
It’s a shame these two never got another
adventure.
But with Temple of Doom set before Raiders
of the Lost Ark, maybe Short Round played
a bigger role in shaping the legendary tomb-raider
then fans realize.
Wilson – Cast Away
When Chuck Noland is stranded on a desert
island, he resorts to talking to a volleyball
to preserve his sanity.
As you might expect, Wilson proves to be an
excellent listener and the best companion
a castaway could have.
Resembling a bloody handprint with eyes, Wilson
provided Chuck with an outlet to discuss his
life and personal connections to the outside
world, reminding him of the reason to stay
alive, and make his way off the island.
We’ll never know exactly how Chuck imagined
Wilson responding to his muttering and musings,
but the volleyball was much, much more than
an inanimate object, offering the final inspiration
he needed to escape.
And their farewell?
As heartbreaking as goodbyes can get.
Thankfully, the film’s final scene shows
that Wilson is destined to return.
Spock – Star Trek
A bold rule-breaker like Captain James Kirk
needs someone who specializes in logic to
balance out his tendencies.
That’s what makes Spock the perfect sidekick
to the Enterprise captain.
The Vulcan’s ability to analyze every situation
and determine the best possible solution makes
him a valuable ally, and his unwillingness
to let emotions get the best of him ensures
he’s cool-headed under pressure.
Intelligent and faithful to the point of sacrificing
his life for his crew, Spock compliments Kirk
in every way, illustrating why they’re destined
to be friends for all time – whether they
like it or not.
Groot – Guardians of the Galaxy
Due to his limited vocabulary and general
aloofness, Groot doesn’t inspire confidence
at first glance.
But when push comes to shove, he’s the kind
of friend anyone would be happy to have.
His heart is always in the right place, as
the wellbeing of his friends is his top priority.
Groot also stands for what is right, setting
off to make millions in Marvel’s space adventure,
but willingly fighting to protect the people
of Xandar from total destruction.
The emotional center of the team, capable
of turning even the hardened Rocket into a
big softie, it’s impossible not to tear
up when he shields his teammates from a crash
landing in the movie’s final battle.
We are Groot, indeed.
Hit-Girl – Kick-Ass
When Dave Lizewski decides to become the superhero
Kick-Ass, he realizes he can’t do it on
his own.
Luckily, he meets Mindy, aka Hit-Girl, partnering
up to show organized crime that they’ve
finally met their match.
Trained by her ex-cop father to become a fierce
crime fighter and seek revenge for her mother’s
death, Hit-Girl is not your typical kid.
No-nonsense and tough to take down in a fight,
her skills rival those of the older Kick-Ass
and show that it’s wise to have her on your
side.
Though Dave is told to look after Mindy, it’s
clear she can take care of herself.
Sidekick doesn’t do her justice.
Chewbacca – Star Wars
Everyone needs a co-pilot, and Han Solo has
the best in the galaxy.
Devoted to Han because of a life debt, Chewie
is always by his best friend’s side with
a heart of gold and a great sense of loyalty.
His physical strength makes him plenty useful
in a fight against Imperial stormtroopers,
but his best trait is his moral center.
Motivated more by helping his companions than
selfish smuggler profits, Chewie is instrumental
in sending Han down the path of becoming a
Galactic hero.
Any Star Wars fan would want a Wookie friend
of their own, and Chewie’s dedication illustrates
why they really are man’s best friends in
a galaxy far, far away.
Samwise Gamgee – Lord of the Rings
It was Frodo Baggins’s plan to destroy the
Ring of Power by heading to Mount Doom all
by himself, but Samwise made a promise to
never leave his best friend, and in the end,
the Lord of the Rings trilogy only had a happy
ending because of his presence.
Incorruptible and fiercely loyal, he always
made sure Frodo stayed on task as his burden
became heavier to bear.
Whenever his master was ready to give up,
Sam would provide words of encouragement and
motivation to renew his dedication.
Risking his life on several occasions and
showing unbelievable courage, “Samwise the
Brave” exemplified what a sidekick should
offer.
The fact that he was one of the only creatures
to ever give up the One Ring willingly has
us convinced he was a hero in disguise all
along.
Those are our picks for the best movie sidekicks.
Are there any we missed?
Which supporting characters are your favorite?
Sound of in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!